[Aplausos]
[Música]
seguro que todos habéis tenido esta
discusión alguna vez con vuestros amigos
porque suben tanto los precios de los
alquileres da igual que viváis en madrid
los ángeles o ciudad de méxico- se trata
de un problema global aunque la primera
pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer es
realmente esto es un problema o es algo
natural
[Música]
hablamos de un fenómeno que se está
dando en casi todas las grandes ciudades
por ejemplo en los ángeles los
alquileres han crecido en un 15% en los
últimos tres años por supuesto que si
tienes un sueldo alto esto no es un gran
problema simplemente sería una molestia
ahora bien vamos a imaginar que eres un
empleado en una tienda de los ángeles
ganarás un sueldo de dos mil dólares al
mes
pues bien un piso una vivienda de 50
metros cuadrados de una sola habitación
en la zona sur que es lo más barato te
puede salir por 1200 dólares esto es un
60 por ciento de tu salario el resto a
duras penas te da para comida ropa y
gastos básicos en otras palabras que
apenas vas a poder ahorrar para que os
hagáis una idea según varios estudios la
situación ideal es que la vivienda te
suponga un tercio de tus ingresos de
esta forma puedes ahorrar pero este
empleado de la tienda de los ángeles
está al borde de la pobreza basta con
que suba un poquito más su alquiler para
que termine en bancarrota y ahí sí que
estaríamos hablando de un problema más
real de lo que parece
la población hombres en los ángeles
crece dramáticamente hasta llegar a las
36.000 personas pero no sólo eso
pensadlo bien en visual politics siempre
decimos que el mundo está mejorando cada
vez somos más ricos más sanos y vivimos
mejor y esto se debe en buena medida a
que la tecnología ha permitido que las
cosas sean más baratas por ejemplo en
los años 70 sólo el 20 por ciento de los
estadounidenses había viajado en avión
porque es muy fácil porque un los
ángeles nueva york costaba el
equivalente actual a 1500 dólares hoy en
día ese mismo vuelo vale alrededor de
200 dólares gracias a eso seguro que
cualquiera de vosotros ha volado en
avión y ha viajado muchísimo más que
nuestros abuelos lo mismo ocurre con
casi todos los bienes de consumo
todos menos uno la vivienda
da igual que compremos o que alquilemos
tendremos que seguir haciendo los mismos
o más sacrificios que las generaciones
anteriores para que os hagáis una idea
en pleno 2019 hay gente en estocolmo en
suecia que está viviendo en un piso de
15 metros cuadrados de hecho en suecia
no es raro que las parejas que se
quieren divorciar esperen varios meses
simplemente porque es complicadísimo
encontrar un piso para el cónyuge que se
tiene que marchar pero y porque suben
tanto los alquileres se puede solucionar
este problema con mejores políticas hoy
vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
oferta demanda y algo más es un hecho
universal y lógico la población crece en
todos los países para que os hagáis una
idea hace sólo 10 años eeuu tenía 300
millones de habitantes en menos de una
década han sumado 27 millones más sin
embargo no todas las ciudades crecen
igual
detroit y cleveland están perdiendo
población y adonde se va toda esta gente
pues exacto a las ciudades más prósperas
como los ángeles o nueva york o san
francisco que están creciendo como la
espuma
[Música]
en otras palabras la demanda de casas en
estos sitios se disparan pero atentos
porque aquí es donde viene el auténtico
problema el auténtico quid de la
cuestión brace en cualquier mercado es
fácil subir la oferta para satisfacer la
demanda por ejemplo vamos a hablar de
nuestro mercado favorito el mercado del
zumo de dinosaurio si arabia saudita
quiere puede aumentar o reducir la
producción de barriles diarios de un mes
para otro y lo mismo pasa con cualquier
otro país petrolero de hecho esto ocurre
muy a menudo y creo que ya os lo hemos
contado millones de veces aquí en visual
político
sin embargo para construir un edificio
necesitamos años y no sólo eso mucha
gente se piensa que el negocio de la
construcción es extremadamente rentable
y que todos los promotores son
millonarios que van con sombrero de copa
y monóculo pero lo cierto es que no es
así construir un bloque de viviendas
requiere inversiones millonarias y los
márgenes de beneficios rondan el 3%
aunque no lo parezca hablamos de un
sector lleno de casos de fracaso y lo
cierto es que necesitamos muchas
muchísimas casas para cubrir la demanda
california necesitaría construir 35
millones de unidades de vivienda para
2025 si quiere cerrar su brecha
inmobiliaria pero y por qué no se
construyen más casas a fin de cuentas si
hay tanta demanda parece que sería un
negocio redondo verdad pues si tenéis
razón solo que hay un pequeño problemita
los planes urbanísticos
básicamente el mercado del suelo está
hiper regulado por los ayuntamientos si
quieres construir una casa en los
ángeles
necesitas un permiso que dependiendo del
barrio puede tardar hasta tres años y
esto ocurre porque los ayuntamientos son
los que deciden dónde y cómo y cuándo se
puede construir y claro cómo sabe el
ayuntamiento si puede permitir o dejar
de permitir hacer más viviendas pues
principalmente con la población hasta
ahora los ángeles ha ido ampliando el
parque de viviendas casi al mismo ritmo
que crecía la población
[Música]
el problema es que una cosa es la
demanda y otra es la población y la
demanda es bastante más alta os voy a
poner un ejemplo y lo vais a entender
muy bien el hecho de que cada vez haya
más gente soltera o que aumente la tasa
de divorcios también hace que aumente la
demanda pensando bien una pareja de
casados son dos personas en una casa
pero imaginad que esa pareja se divorcia
automáticamente necesitan una casa más
la población no ha crecido pero sin
embargo la demanda se ha duplicado de
nuevo hemos usado el ejemplo de los
ángeles pero ocurre lo mismo en madrid
berlín o cualquier otra gran ciudad
muchos dicen que la solución es
construir más casas otros dicen que la
solución sería liberalizar el mercado de
la vivienda y en europa muchas ciudades
están apostando por todo lo contrario a
liberalizar es decir poner controles a
los precios y que creéis que está
pasando os parece que es una buena idea
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y el auténtico síndrome de estocolmo
normalmente cada vez que se habla de
suecia es para ponerlos como un ejemplo
a seguir los suecos disfrutan de un
estado del bienestar muy pero que muy
generoso pero a la vez tienen una
economía abierta con empresas punteras
entre otras está la startup más famosa
de europa aunque bueno tal vez no se
queden en el país por mucho tiempo
atentos a las noticias
spotify amenaza con dejar suecia y
aceituna protestó de startups en
estocolmo y os preguntaréis por qué las
startups se quieren ir de suecia es por
los impuestos altos pues la razón es
porque no pueden contratar talento de
fuera del país y diréis aver fonseca
esto sí que no nos lo creemos si suecia
todo el mundo sabe que es un país súper
abierto a la inmigración y si lo es
sobre el papel ahora bien si queréis
mudarnos a estocolmo os deseo mucha
suerte encontrando el piso veréis
mientras hacía este vídeo hablé con un
chico que trabajó para una startup sueca
durante un año y medio cobra un sueldo
de unos dos mil novecientos euros al mes
pero más de la mitad se le iba en pagar
el alquiler y creedme no es el caso más
dramático encontrar un piso en estocolmo
es tan complicado que mucha gente llega
a estar varios meses en una ardilla en
vic y diréis pero porque qué
problemática
pues todo empezó en los años 50 por
aquel entonces suecia necesitaba casas y
el gobierno socialdemócrata se puso
manos a la obra construyeron más de un
millón de casas en muy poquitos años la
idea era que estas casas se pondrían en
un alquiler a un precio muy reducido un
precio controlado por el estado así que
durante estos años los suecos estaban
encantados podían solicitar una vivienda
de protección oficial y vivir con
alquileres de unos 300 o 400 euros de
hoy en día sin embargo las cosas
cambiaron en los años 90 en esos años
suecia se sumió en una de las peores
crisis de su historia y sin dinero el
gobierno ya no podía construir más casas
así que todas esas obras se pararon en
seco
[Música]
sin embargo las regulaciones hadad
claire esas regulaciones tan
restrictivas que prácticamente sólo
permitían el alquiler de viviendas de
protección oficial se mantuvieron y
creedme la situación no podía ser peor
por un lado tenemos lo que llaman el
alquiler de primera mano que son las
viviendas de protección oficial
básicamente lo primero que hace un sueco
cuando cumple los 18 años es registrarse
en la base de datos de viviendas de
protección oficial si tiene suerte
dentro de 13 o 16 años le llamarán
diciéndole que por fin puede encontrar
su apartamento de dos habitaciones en el
centro de estocolmo por el módico precio
de seiscientos euros un mes
[Música]
y en otras palabras que lo que no se
paga con dinero se paga con tiempo de
espera y todo esto explica por qué el 25
por ciento de los suecos no deja la casa
de sus padres hasta los 30 años de hecho
eso explica también porque suecia está
pasando de ser una sociedad de
inquilinos a una sociedad de
propietarios y os preguntaréis y qué
pasa con los que no somos suecos qué
pasa si eres un inmigrante y no tienes
esa familia que te puede acoger pues
bien en este caso bienvenido al
maravilloso mundo del alquiler de
segunda mano que podríamos llamarlo el
auténtico síndrome de estocolmo los
frutos básicamente piensan que hacer
negocio con el alquiler es alto
así que de entrada sólo hay unas pocas
casas que se pueden poner en un alquiler
legalmente pero incluso aunque la ley se
lo permita la comunidad de vecinos puede
prohibirse lo y si habéis oído bien en
este país tu comunidad de vecinos puede
decirte que no alquiler o que no renueve
este contrato con el inquilino de hecho
también hay topes para los contratos de
alquiler es muy normal encontrar
contratos de seis meses por ejemplo y
eso explica que en un país con un nivel
de vida tan alto tengamos a gente que
vive en apartamentos de 15 metros
cuadrados es básicamente lo mejor que
han podido encontrar pero de nuevo el
mayor problema no es la incomodidad el
mayor problema es este
[Música]
suez investiga los disturbios en un
suburbio para inmigrantes de estocolmo
exacto los inmigrantes más pobres no
tienen una startup que les busque un
piso así que se concentran en las zonas
más pobres y generan guetos y sí ya lo
sé todos habéis visto muchísimos vídeos
conspiranoicos que exageran la violencia
en estos guetos de suecia pero vamos a
ser honestos aunque el problema no sea
tan grave como lo pintan ciertos medios
de comunicación
es cierto que suecia tiene un problema
de criminalidad del que ya hablaremos
algún día por cierto que si sois nuevos
en este canal y os está gustando este
vídeo suscribiros y darle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones os llegará una
notificación al móvil cada vez que
publicamos y sacamos vídeos todas las
semanas siempre son igual de
interesantes así que de verdad
suscribiros a visual polític que es
gratis y se aprende un montón pero
volviendo al tema que nos ocupa esta
crisis de estocolmo se podría resolver
construyendo más casas pero seamos
honestos por mucho que se levanten
80.000 viviendas nuevas al año como
proponen muchos expertos y muchos
organismos necesitan cambiar sus leyes
de alquiler
no va a servir de nada y ahora os
preguntaréis vale fonseca pero hay algún
ejemplo de ciudad que si haya
solucionado el problema de los
alquileres
pues si tenemos una respuesta y ahora
mismo la vamos a ver
[Música]
bien alquileres para todos austria es
uno de los países más ricos de europa el
salario medio está por encima de los dos
mil setecientos euros al mes en viana no
es raro conseguir contratos de trabajo
por tres mil quinientos euros al mes sin
embargo los alquileres están al mismo
nivel de una ciudad como madrid por mil
quinientos euros puedes encontrar un
piso de 80 metros cuadrados en el centro
de la ciudad por ejemplo y ya se lo que
estáis pensando seguro que ahora estos
de visual polític nos van a vender como
viena es otro ejemplo más de libre
mercado que funciona maravillosamente
bien verdad viva el capitalismo pues no
de hecho todo lo contrario
básicamente el ayuntamiento de viena es
algo así como una empresa promotora y a
la vez es el mayor casero de la ciudad
tras la segunda guerra mundial me dio
bien a quedó devastada por las bombas
así que el consistorio pago las
reparaciones de todas las casas y
después dijeron oye pues ya que hemos
reconstruido todas estas casas supongo
que ahora tendremos derecho para
alquilar las bajo nuestras propias
condiciones y así es como comenzó el
programa de vivienda pública más
ambicioso del mundo el 80 por ciento de
los vieneses viven de alquiler habéis
oído bien y el 60% de esos alquileres
son viviendas de protección oficial
algunos de los edificios pertenecen a
cooperativas y otros pertenecen al
ayuntamiento pero todos tienen precios
controlados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y esperar un momento porque no hablamos
de alquileres normales en viena los
contratos de alquiler no solo son para
toda la vida es que también se pueden
heredar es decir a efectos prácticos son
algo así como derechos de propiedad
limitados siempre y cuando no te mudes
el piso es tuyo y creedme tenéis que ver
las casas en eeuu o en reino unido- las
viviendas protegidas son sinónimo de
casas baratas y de mala calidad aquí es
todo lo contrario zonas comunes piscina
gimnasio y hasta saunas en algunos casos
podemos encontrarnos situaciones
absurdas preparando este vídeo hablé con
el ayuntamiento de viena y me dieron
varios casos muy curiosos por ejemplo
una chica que vive en un apartamento de
100 metros cuadrados y en metros
cuadrados en el centro de viena cuánto
creéis que paga 400 euros al mes pues
resulta que su vecino que vive en un
piso similar paga dos mil euros y diréis
pero cómo es esto posible pues muy
sencillo su vecino está en ese 40% de
casas que no son de protección oficial
es decir que al igual que en estocolmo
aquí tenemos dos tipos de alquiler
precio
y precio libre y os preguntaréis por qué
aquí no tienen listas de espera y la
respuesta la tenéis aquí
[Música]
anualmente viena se gasta alrededor de
600 millones de euros en viviendas
sociales en comparación a alemania con
una población 45 veces mayor se gasta
400 millones en todo el país en otras
palabras que el modelo de viena tiene
tres cosas que le hacen único lo primero
es que están continuamente construyendo
casas lo segundo es que estas casas son
viviendas de protección oficial sí pero
no se entregan en propiedad sino que se
entregan en alquiler y tres compite el
sistema público con un sistema privado
que también tiene suficiente oferta como
para satisfacer a la demanda y os
preguntaréis pero cómo funciona este
sistema pues bien vamos a imaginar que
os mudáis a viena en un primer momento
no podéis pedir un piso de protección
oficial pero no pasa nada hay más de 290
mil pisos que están en un régimen de
libre mercado así que no es
especialmente difícil encontrar un sitio
donde poder hospedar al cabo de dos o
tres años
ya podéis aplicar para una vivienda de
protección oficial dependiendo del
estatus familiar los ingresos y vuestras
propias preferencias podréis encontrar
un piso en más
o menos tiempo pero normalmente hablamos
de tiempos de espera de no más de dos
años
por supuesto que este modelo también
tiene sus desventajas de entrada una vez
has encontrado un piso que te gusta no
te vas a ir de ahí ni con aguarrás de
hecho es un modelo que reduce bastante
la libertad de elección en la mayor
parte de los casos es el ayuntamiento
quién decide dónde vives y en qué
condiciones y por supuesto es un modelo
que depende demasiado de un único actor
el ayuntamiento es decir quien mientras
la administración austriaca tenga dinero
no hay problema habrá pisos para todos
ahora bien bastaría una crisis para que
viene dejará de construir y claro con
este modelo apenas hay incentivos para
las empresas privadas así que en el
momento en el cual la oferta de pisos
deje de aumentar este modelo bienes se
iría a freír churros ahora bien por el
momento hay que reconocer que está
funcionando así que ahora la pregunta es
sería posible combinar este modelo
bienes con el libre mercado creéis que
se puede exportar este sistema a vuestra
ciudad os gustaría vivir siempre de
alquiler si las condiciones fueran
buenas podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y antes de terminar
me gustaría dar las gracias a marc solo
y a jaime chapinal por ayuda
con los datos sobre los alquileres de
estocolmo también quiero dar las gracias
al ayuntamiento de viena que me han
contestado a todas mis preguntas y han
sido super amables y por supuesto
recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a visual
polític y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]